am i and/or my big idea good enough am I
good enough what do you think I'd say a
bit of advice I got you know again I
started I grow to small businesses and
the great thing about small business
with street fighters were operated where
are their customers all the time
and and everything you should focus is
actually doing good enough and learning
and improving I wouldn't advocate number
one don't try and come up back to your
first point really Evan lived the Holy
Grail
don't worry about perfection actually
get a business off the ground engage the
customers get a flight out
I get the service proposition now and
then learn fast improve so I kind of
think if you think it's good enough
you're passionate about it and you love
what you're doing and you think there's
a gap in the market go and find out
test-drive it we could be friends could
be you know trauma customers and then
you'll find out really quickly whether
it's good enough you know the rubber
hits the road when customers tell you
that you've got the best product in the
world and you know view actually the
early customers again when I kind of
started this business in California we
said the first 20 customers they've got
to be raving fans they've got to be
evangelists they've got a you know when
you cut into the DNA of them they gotta
believe in us we're there for them build
trust collect because you know with all
these things again it with social media
there's 20 guys from to come thousands
of guys and you know it goes viral so I
wouldn't worry too much about analyzing
again is it good enough I'm getting to
the execution phase and start test on
and again one of the phrase I'll use
around here is a class strategy of B
class execution is always inferior to be
faster and DNA class execution get out
and find out what works and prove it
yeah I love it I wanna I love that I
love that a Class B Class thing is cool
I might I might take that from you
mindset is super important here uh you
have to believe you know right believe
you gotta believe that your idea is good
enough and every major breakthrough that
I've had in my business career has been
because I've shattered a limiting belief
that I had in my first business was a it
was a biotech software company I was 19
years old I was selling to scientists
and researchers who were three times my
age at PhD in sultans degrees and the
story I told myself was I'm too young to
do this they're never gonna take me
seriously and as long as I believe that
as long as I was a story I told myself
then it was a self-fulfilling prophecy
that actually happened and then the
shift came when I realized that hey I
can actually provide value to these
people right they don't care about my
background and my credentials as long as
I can actually help them accomplish
something important in what they're
doing well and and like we'd all have
our own limiting beliefs we tell
ourselves were too young we're too old
we don't have the right parents we don't
have the educational background I don't
have enough money I don't have you know
whatever excuse you come up with as long
as you believe that story then it's
gonna come true and again once you
realize that that's just a story you're
telling yourself and you accept
responsibility for your life and not
blame the conditions then you can see if
they break through your business